hey everyone this is John Roca for
Collider I'm here with the co-writer of
this new remake reboot reimagining I
think we're still trying to figure it
out black Christmas it's out now April
wolf how are you April
great how are you I'm good I'm loving
this shirt is because it gets me right
in the mood to talk about this stuff
it's like wearing a warm winter blanket
yeah no I think it's perfect for the
movie as well as got some styles of
Flash and you can't help but keep white
looking at it so let me say all about
this this is such a gutsy gutsy film I
appreciate that it puts this issue of
female male relationships in 2019 the
idea of date rape all of it is right
here for you to consume in a horror film
which kind of harkens back to some of
the origins of horror having these
social aspects to it how important was
that for you to put that in the movie
well I think that when you're remaking
something like black Christmas or
reimagining which is what we would call
it you need to give due credit to Bob
Clark in his original vision because you
know that movie was largely about
domestic violence it was largely about
abortion rights and about you know women
who were new on campus you know like
they at that point in time when that
movie was made women were not allowed to
be in a lot of colleges and universities
and so all of a sudden you have these
sororities that pop up that become like
a place of protection for these women
so when we're remaking it and
reimagining for 2019 you have to make
sure that that social aspect is there to
kind of give credit to what Bob Clark
was doing you know like that's our
homage to him yeah what I was talking
with Sofia or earlier the director of
the film she said to me that they asked
her to direct before there was even a
script so what point did you come on to
the process and how did that come about
for you well so Sofia um was working on
a couple of things but she had read a
script of mine a psychological thriller
that you know she really liked and she
was looking for someone to collaborate
with because um you know I think in her
words for a little while she was kind of
feeling hampered by the slasher genre
okay and because you know we're just in
a different time of slashers you know
like what what what do you do how can
you do it new and
I love horror and that's kind of like my
backbone is is working in that genre and
so she knew that I would be kind of a
kindred soul yeah and so she brought me
on and we got to just kind of
immediately jump in and collaborate
because you know she had a vision that
she needed to fulfill and she was going
to direct it and that was a really cool
thing cuz you're writing for and with
the same person who's just like no
that's not gonna work for me okay well
here's something else was this better
for your vision you know so very
collaborative process you absolutely how
much of and I hope I feel free not
dancers but how much of the experience
is for maybe your life or Sophia's life
or in this movie possibly from the
experiences that Riley goes through is
any of that there for you yes okay yeah
it's definitely in there for it feels
very powerful as I'm watching it yeah
it's um we definitely drew from a lot of
personal experience not just for Riley's
thing but even kind of smaller dilemmas
smaller like arguments kind of
infighting with it like it just felt
like we needed to kind of put our vision
of what that dynamic between women and
2019 is yeah and I think that's what the
what's really great about the script and
great about the movie is that you get so
many different points of views and we're
in this transition time in 2019 of how
do we speak if we were taught to speak a
certain way but how do we speak down
women and/or Chris like Chris is
protesting yes I did why not like you
put it all out there put it all in the
script a lot gets covered here I find it
to be an incredibly topical approach to
this film it isn't just a horror so I
appreciate that very much well also for
2019 if you look at the youth if you
look at these characters who are 21 and
their avatars in the real world like
right it is nearly impossible to not be
active and socially conscious and
political and so to make this movie in
2019 and not have that seems
disingenuous I think it doesn't seem
realistic I think that's the guts of the
movie that's what I appreciate about the
movies it puts it out there you deal
with it yeah I'm not gonna sugarcoat it
when I can make a soft for you you deal
with it this is what's happened it is
overt ya know I'd just be blood exactly
right
one last thing who commit to who's gonna
take credit for writing the song the
lyrics for the song did you write the
lyrics of the song or did she write the
loose actually I'm not sure if I should
I mean it's Riki Lindhome Oh Oh from oh
it's and garfunkel I think yeah yeah
fantastic I mean I hope that I can say
that she shall look cut it out of you
can yeah all right well thank you so
much April wolf before the film Black
Christmas go see this thing trust me
it's gonna surprise you